[Music]
Buhler hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to why
what is this I'm getting anti religious
commentary a hint of one dimensional
villains and/or rednecks and they so saw
of something really stupid trying to
come across this Gary but instead coming
across this really stupid
it's Steven James hi
[Music]
sometimes I feel bad began this guy's
worse work but his worst work is clearly
having so much fun being his worst work
that in the end and everybody's having a
good time so let's keep the nostalgia
wean tradition going by looking at his
2003 film the story where aliens come
out of people's butts I'm a dreamcatcher
I mean the story where aliens come out
of people's butts
yep this was the first book King rode
after his nearly fatal car accident in
does it show oh my god
what King it's hard to tell this is the
film everyone remembers specifically for
one reason
it has monsters that explode out of your
ass
because apparently there's nothing more
terrifying than shitweasels you may
laugh at me calling them that but that's
the official term even the movie gives
them what about the shitweasels King
said in an interview that he want to do
for the toilet what psycho did for the
shower but I don't think you can do that
when shit weasel is the name that's
being thrown around what about the shit
weasels
so let's take a look at what obviously
came out of somebody's ass come on King
that joke was gift-wrapped by you this
is dreamcatcher
we open with every early 2000s credit
sequence with blurry close-ups of things
yeah you're every kid who laid his head
on the desk and held as a racer to his
eye as we see the director as the writer
of The Empire Strikes Back in the force
awakens and clearly he's still getting
his no fetish on seriously is this a
thing it starts with a psychiatrist
named Henry who can read his patients
minds because he's a psychic Wow not
even a minute in and we have a trope
that he uses all the time she called out
to you from that big fancy oak bed how
could you know what happened doesn't
matter okay looking I know everybody has
a style but there's only so many ways I
can make jokes about you using the same
cliches the Stephen King drinking game
the Stephen King board game the trope
raiser the dart board The Twilight Zone
parody I know you're very comfortable
doing the same thing over and over and
over but I'm not for the most part do I
really have to find a new way to make
fun of your fear of originality hey
where's this take place anyway and the
board belongs to you Tamra which
category would you like to choose
let's do unexplained psychics for 200
you'll find children and/or adults can
do literally beyond explain with their
minds here Alka what does every Stephen
King story ever written
alright annoying
long flashbacks for 400 that is the
video Daily Double look boys from the
pass being threatened by bullies has
developed as wet cardboard Tamra what is
every Stephen King story ever written
correct
let's do up for 600 an alcoholic of
course of course an alcoholic jester
what was the point of me being here
though I'm so sorry the correct answer
was what is every Stephen King story
ever written oh I'm seriously asking
what is the point of me being here you
needed a third space to be filled can I
still get this sandwich you promised me
join us next time on Stephen King
jeopardy which will be almost
immediately so Henry uses his psychic
powers to help paranoid people think
they're even more paranoid very do you
think this compulsive eating has
something to do with thinking you killed
your mother that you're eating yourself
to death in my head
leave me alone subtle use of your talent
what happens to this guy
create himself to death kill the world
we've been cut to Jason Lee where he
usually is after shooting a Chipmunks
movie as he gives a call to his other
psychic friend Jonesy
played by Damian Lewis wanna talk now
you're trying to get home to Carl and
the kids what's up I'm waiting to be
cast as Deadpool that's Ryan Reynolds
who Jason Lee goddammit but Jonesy is
suddenly inspired to do his best even
King in prison
if he didn't want people to talk about
he won't have written that in there in
fact it's kind of amazing how much this
scene doesn't fit after being picked up
by that year's winner of horse actress
and an ambulance I think it's no good I
think he's gone yeah I'd want to die
after hearing that read - he
spontaneously comes back to life and we
cut to six months later where he seems
perfectly fine what was the point of
that it said later through some
complicated King writing that because he
technically died and came back this
blocks off part of his mind from the
alien he came back from
it must have changed him somehow but
while they just use the excuse that he
psychic is the reason why it's a lot
shorter and keeps the story more focused
this doesn't add anything to anything
except an excuse for me to play funny
sound effects over it unless it somehow
ties into that car being the love child
of Christine and the Green Goblin truck
from Maximum Overdrive in which case
take all the time you need on that story
there are no wrong choices there our
four psychic friends meet up yearly in
their cabin in the woods to be in their
cabin in the woods I don't know I don't
get camping near the movies when people
wake up together in the morning they
immediately start kissing nothing and
going at it but what they never do is
get up first take a leak and brush their
goddamn teeth okay you do not get to
make fun of other movie cliches if one
of them was like Hayes do we talk about
Stephen King cliches there before
skeletons never heard from again I'm
filing that in though gives you shit
section of my memory warehouse
what's the memory warehouse speaking of
libraries of cliches they establish that
everybody's mind has a memory warehouse
obviously not a bad idea especially for
a story about mind control it even has a
spot for recycled sepia-tone memories
some kids shirt so it's new scooby-doo
that was important to know scooby-doo
season for Casey Kasem was stole shaggy
before the dark times at the scrappy
years hey they see a mentally disabled
boy named Douglas or as he says duddits
being beaten up by boys you better watch
it why is that I know who you are
I'm trembling with fear so what do you
think people will say when we tell them
what we caught you doing call me crazy I
just don't like seeing scenes of kids
named Douglas getting beaten up
give the word Henry it's Pete more no
one can catch him it went straight to
his house tell his mother you did why
are you asking for trouble likes getting
attention do you know he likes okay this
isn't a debate over a new bill its
bullies being bullies Weiss is taking so
long
you want to fight us yes why you lose
why and on its own the world wants to
leave said it will the senator yield so
they save Toby Neil Patrick McGuire and
singing to him this gets my magic potty
baby to piss up a storm back in modern
day they come across a hunter in the
woods I'm hunting wabbits who seems to
be ill so they take him inside hi Joe
Clarendon call me beaver intentionally
but our hunter seems to be having
terrible gas coming out both ends
again that doesn't seem particularly
scary critic
we've peed our pants isn't that mostly
terrifying and kind of humorous oh it's
mostly humor isn't kind of ridiculous
it's complex it's stupid
stupidly complex complexly stupid you
just doesn't see how this can possibly
be an alien invasion god help you with
our snot gets infected too I'd like to
see you try to find a humor in that you
know sometimes I feel bad writing you
two so dumb yeah what the hell man can
you ever be smart well you could just be
a series of catchphrases like Jason Lee
for some reason that tried to give him
one-liners that clearly wouldn't catch
on but they try to hammer in anyway
that's kind of embarrassing fuck me
Freddy ditch in a buzzsaw fuck me Freddy
crimen nedley's fuck me Freddy fuckery
is trying to fuck a road kid my double
fucker Oh real Java Navas
well-beloved dub dub rikki-tikki-tavi
bitch huh that's strange I don't
remember those well I remember that you
don't have to set our work here is done
that really has got to catch on
meanwhile the other two nearly crash
into a lady just sitting in the middle
of the road I guess it is funny hello
hello I'll be a jump-scare for the
evening
oh sorry I have shotgun arm syndrome
can't help it while the animals reenact
Alaskan lion king a helicopter is seen
flying overhead
temporary quarantine you must stay where
you are baby 20 plastic idea here yeah
we can totally hear you
you are smart but it looks like they're
hunter pal is sicker than they realized
go away open the door we have to break
it down have some privacy let's do it
I'm not all in absolutely positive I
want to go in there she's dying
scooby-doo we do we got some work to do
now well now you said that I know you're
serious I mean you'd have a stronger
argument if you pointed out Flintstones
we're a modern Stone Age family but
nevertheless that's strong words do I
meet George Jetson thunder thunder
thundercats ducktales woohoo I got
enough fella snap out of it oh my god Oh
Tiny Toon Adventures so there seems to
be an awful monster they can't flush
down oh and an alien creature that Lee
sits on to stop from getting out damn it
ever seen Jason Lee so terrified what
could be under there to scare him so
much oh of course
future squeak walls think of all the
young guys make a deal with Pun title
I'll rap music old Hulk Japan I'm gonna
just sound cold holy chick and of course
the Halloween special scare triplet
we're coming for you Dave so while the
chip weasel seems under control he no
joke lets them out because he wanted his
toothpick are you freaking kidding me
all right I get that they're trying to
hint at some sort of compulsion with him
but even an OCD person wouldn't be like
oh my god if I let go of this trigger a
bomb will explode you know this could be
a little bit more symmetrical but it
gets even sillier now that the monsters
out it leads to some pretty goofy stuff
like fighting him off with a whele brush
cutting his hand off and looking only
slightly annoyed by it and even a 90s
crotch shot
I feel like Daniel Stern should do a
girly cry from home alone
the creature ends up killing him as
we're shown Stephen King letdown alien
number 905 who takes control of his body
meanwhile we're introduced to two albino
caterpillars with Morgan Freeman's face
attached who points out that these alien
creatures who infect the human body and
have their young burst out in bloody
ways it's a bit familiar the men call
the red stuff Ripley after to draw in
the Alien movies see what I did there
that immediately doesn't make it a
ripoff I learned my craft from the rocky
and bullwinkle movie shut up Kelly step
right yeah
Freeman plays a guy who really knows his
shit like making his soldiers give
scouts honor only to shoot their fingers
off that was nice
it talks about tons of Neela's military
information that honestly plays little
to no part in anything I never picked
terrain like this before
so you know the blue unit catechism I
hand-picked every man in blue boy group
I know what rules are really good at
operating they were visited the world
they wouldn't rather home tell me how we
do Ellen fast and hard - OH - disobeys
our superiors orders yeah you know what
this all leads to at one point Freeman
tries to shoot our hero and he fails
that's it so why are we listening to all
this there's a difference of opinion
about the Ripley who has an opinion
three-star general Matheson when did you
see him call man yesterday and what is
the fault of opinion it's like
dedicating a half-hour of Snow White to
talk about the Queen's foreign policies
and Social Affairs nobody gives a shit
you fall off a cliff why are we stuck
with this dueling pair of dr.wily
mustaches what about the shit weasels oh
yeah cuz he says that that kind makes it
worth it but the lady from before also
has an alien shit out her ass sorry King
it'll always be funny as Peter tries to
calm down by showing how well he can
imitate Bill Paxton so goddamn good I
can't believe he's
human I knew you would hi the shit
weasel wants revenge for attacking his
head so he attacks his head in return
these things always go for the twin I'll
never sing better tell them again I'll
show you how can you eat fried Munich uh
no no man stands up immediately after
that the correct response is unzip your
fly and crawl around in the snow like a
dog who has worms not that matters
though is the possessed body of Jonesy
it's about to meet up with it how do we
know he's possessed well his head Chun's
whenever he turns which goes really
great with his hood sound effect yeah
even this hood has a sound effect I
swear to god I'm not adding this
what are these he only is trying to be
diabolical Mike wins lose and for no
explained reason whatsoever he suddenly
has an English accent what was that mr.
Jones what we just lost on the road
there oh my god I can tell just from
that couple of seconds you have already
earned your spot in the Hall of Fame of
over the top Stephen King villains
welcome to the lineup I don't need you
to give me any more if I be so blessed
if you do are you speaking to me
yes I am mr. Jones or is it Jonesy
that's what your friends call you isn't
it let's be friends I guess having an
alien take over your mind turns you into
a drunk Simon pay I'm borrowing you
we're going to take a little journey
fuck you I know what that expression
means it makes no sense but it's amazing
Pete I need you to get onto the
snowmobile right now you sound like one
of those Jeff bumps even in the memory
warehouse Jonesy has partially blocked
off that doesn't stop evil Eric Idle
from knocking on his echoey door Let Me
In what have you got in that part of
your mind it'll just take me a while to
find them think about letting me in it's
the polite thing to do
man Haley's got some good backup
accompaniment you know this guy shaft is
a mean mother I'm just talking about
shaft weekend
these extraterrestrials have an
interesting way of doing things don't
think guys hmm now Tamra is it me or do
you guys seem a bit more British than
usual I don't know what you mean
we're just our normal American cells
sure you haven't been taken over by
aliens cuz it would just make too much
sense yes okay well go back to doing
whatever non-alien things you were doing
okay
under why crave mushy peas all the Sun
you
hey guys quick announcement I am going
to be at Rhode Island comic-con this
year November 11 to the 13th
now this is kind of a big deal because
if you look at the guest list they have
big names like Stanley gal gadot Kate
Beckinsale Alice Cooper LA huge names
but not that many internet people I'm
one of the few ones there so it's really
important that you come and say hi and
stuff like that of course the other
guest but I definitely say hi to me
because that will encourage them to see
and get more internet people because
there's not that many very if there are
more because they've been released the
whole guest list yet if there are more
go see them too because we definitely
want to encourage them to bring out more
internet celebrities and I hear this is
a phenomenal con so definitely come say
hi would love to see you guys and
hopefully I'll see you there
take care
you
meanwhile Freeman takes the two moths
tape to his eyebrows to the alien ship
and tries to destroy we can get these
male self destructing back off don't you
love it in movies when the military
never do as they're told because one in
their history isn't ever hammer then
they should follow orders disrespectful
piece of shit get this while the alien
part of Jonesy's mind is distracted
Jonesy sneaks out and tries to pull all
the information on duddits into the
locked room with him okay open to a
visual representation of the mind and
how its being altered but um mental
Jonesy has a limp what takes the mental
alien so long to get to him he took over
his mind pretty fast before why does the
alien recognize where mental Jonesy is
sometimes but not other times how our
memories heavy or heavy enough to earn a
grunt noise I mean does it make any
sense to you guys
no come on how come let me see inside
your mind we can do cool whispering
together damn why is it that whenever we
see you trying to scare us through a
door I've soaked up Oh your memories of
the critics purge review and I know that
you're deathly afraid of British people
based on all those American movies where
they play bad guys
it's true I've absorbed everything from
the movies you like I'm a little film
brain and I'll get you and your little
camera to time to thicken camera don't
you don't fool me
alien crumpet I'm gonna find a way to
brexit out of here it's futile I've
mastered the ability to control your
mind and there is absolutely no escape
excuse me stay scared hello hello hello
hello hello hey now begin there
yeah boy this advanced alien race sure
is easy to do yeah you want to grab a
bite up for tulips sounds good where are
they
how about connect with me one I don't
like fur machines on you to fix you in
the Lego set in my brain that's so
Malcolm and Tamara another strange thing
this film suddenly implements or wipes
not that there's anything wrong with
using him in a film but they literally
come in an hour and a half into the
movie there hasn't been one before and
then suddenly they're all over the place
maybe he knew the movie was going south
so he wanted remind people they worked
on Star Wars I keep expecting one of
those wipes to reveal r2d2
[Music]
so whoever gets caught in quarantine but
he convinces Freeman's second-in-command
that Freeman is nuts and going to kill
everybody in the area the soldier agrees
with him so he decides to break Henry
out shred me down figure you read my
mind get out of the way a perfectly
valid point but Jonesy calls Henry
through a phone in his mind and Henry
answers his gun to talk Oh Jonesy oh my
god
where's he taking you Massachusetts he
is it got it okay this is still a scary
film right
what's it ever meant to be scary because
I started to look like a mix of Russian
roulette and whose line is it anyway
dang in there guilty Jonesy Jonesy
Jonesy I can't hear you hello operator
operator oh that's a lobby and you know
this dude's just thinking oh my god I've
killed us all I'm gonna be
court-martialed for this loon and I
doomed the human race you know Oh
Pokemon gotta catch em all so they find
out where duddits is who's now played by
Donnie Wahlberg looking how hath the new
kids on the block look right now and he
tells his mom he needs to go stop an
alien invasion she of course has no
problem with this goodbye
be good boy now go save the world
and go score a touchdown but it turns
out the gun has a tracking device
because of course it does so Freeman
chases after them and they pray that
they can outrun him before their timp
like nelson melts I'm not even sure why
I used a helicopter my high brow is
gonna follow me here fast enough again
they're both trying to stop the aliens
so this all seems pretty pointless but
let's wait and see let's wait and see
yeah it wasn't active alien Jonesy shows
his true form and wants to contaminate
the drinking water supply with alien
sperm but thankfully duddits comes in to
save the day we doing we are some more
Padula weirdest cartoon tie-in ever he
goes to fight the men in black bug and
it's revealed why duddits was the way he
was of course he wasn't alien all along
do you think his mother knew that was
she impregnated was he taken over by the
alien did he show up in a basket like a
1920s cartoon now we'll never know
because the alien is defeated the last
bug is squashed and that's it either
decide against an ending because I guess
they figured we suffered enough um
thanks this movie is all sorts of silly
trying to somehow be taken seriously
maybe Kings writing could have made some
of these ideas work better in the book
but as a film it's hilariously
ridiculous the only real downside is how
slow it is there's a lot of pointless
talking slow moving scenes and long
periods of black nothingness that offer
nothing visually or comedic ly
entertaining but it does still have evil
British aliens crazy Morgan Freeman's
and of course shitweasels if that sounds
insane enough to tickle your funny bone
then this
definitely one to check out speaking of
weird what's been up with you guys
recently you look like a Canadian rap
group it's time to begin a hostile
takeover critic it's time for end of
maniacs
a bugger another British heritage
you
Chester
[Music]
of course Chester was an alien all along
that's why he acted so strange that's
why he was different from everyone else
that was just an alien disguised as me
I'm still really here oh you really
think all of my mental problems is
because I was an alien huh it's not like
that no no I get it
he can't be because of how I was born or
my environment clearly being an alien
explains it just as well no it's like if
an ancient person walks by and I'm like
whoa maybe he looks that way because
he's an alien it's a perfectly a jury's
it I hope I will be seen as more than
just an excuse for your stereotype sir
now if you'll excuse me I have serious
work to do I'm the Nostalgia Critic and
happy flushing
[Music]
coming next weakest the top 11 gravity
falls episodes you demanded it we're
giving it to you but you can see it now
under vessels ad free early access just
three dollars a month to see tons of
people's videos early as well as a bunch
of other extra features check it out and
get the early scoop
[Music]
you
scooby-do-be-do we got some work to do
now
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this one you probably heard of
before hell you probably shop there
before it's goodwill goodwill is North
America's leading nonprofit provider of
education training and career services
for people with disadvantages as well as
those with physical mental and emotional
disabilities you see their shops
everywhere you probably gone there
before so you know where the money goes
how many great people are out there that
give donations and of course how
effective it is 37 million people acts
as goodwill services to advance their
careers and manage their finances over
three hundred twelve thousand people
earned jobs with goodwills health
forty-two thousand goodwill participants
and employers earned credentials that
can allow them to earn an additional
fourteen point two billion dollars
throughout their careers on top of that
there's Goodwill Industries
International which is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization they advocate for
public policies that provide job
training programs employment placement
services and other local programs for
people having a hard time finding
employment they of course appreciate
your donations but the great thing is
you don't even have to do that you can
just go to their store buy their stuff
see all the incredible things that they
got and at what great prices and clearly
see how it's all going to a good cause
you can see how they do it on their
YouTube channel all the people they've
helped out over the years all the jobs
they've gotten it's a wonderful service
that sometimes we take for granted but
you can show your thanks by going to
their site opening up your heart and
helping those in need